um it being 10 o'clock uh I'm going to
open the division three work session to
discuss House Bill 49. uh this is a
basically a continuation of a
conversation we began last Friday
we we got a lot of progress done I think
but but we we didn't complete the
conversation so
um so this is an attempt to sort of go
back to HB 49 go back back to the
amendment that was offered by
by representative walner
and and before we broke huddle
I pointed out that I had two amendments
and I named them
that I'd like to be able to discuss
today
so
um there this is a very hot topic
the sununu center
is scheduled to close on one March and I
think today is the eighth
so so you can you can hear the clock
ticking I think
um
if we don't do exactly what the Senate
did with sb1 when the full finance
committee gets it tomorrow
uh then we open up some questions about
whether or not uh whatever we do that's
different
can get turned around through the house
and back over the senate in time for
them to do their thing
to
um to get it to the governor before
March 1st so so there's just there's
just authentic time pressure here now
now there is some good news uh on that
front so it's not it's not complete
Panic we we uh the speaker we the
speaker uh have been talking to
um Senator Bradley and Senator Carson uh
about sb1
they are aware that we may not be in a
position we maybe we are but we may not
be in a position to send them sb1
approved by the house
um and and so
um Senator Bradley when I spoke to him
this morning is anticipating kind of I
wouldn't call it the worst case scenario
but it would it would be it would be not
the best case scenario for the Senate
they would have to receive something
from us
uh and that they would have to uh
dispose of it rapidly uh and favorably
in order to get it to the governor on
time to forestall the one March closure
date it's there seems to be a path to
success though that's the good news and
I think as long as we
do the best we can
to re respect the fact that they've
voted 24 to nothing for sb1
that's pretty it's a pretty strong vote
if we can respect some of what that work
accomplishment was
um I I I I think the state can be in a
really good place for taking care of
this this situation
so
um
so that's kind of my introduction to to
where we're at uh I understand that uh
representative nordgren is not going to
be able to be in the room with us but
that she's watching uh live
um could somebody confirm or I could I
would like to to to one of our
conversations representative Wallner I
want to make sure that when we go around
and we talk about things even though
that she's not here if she were to be
talking to somebody I just don't want to
um do you know does anyone have comms
I I'm not going to ask you to do that
because that would probably create all
kinds of precedent and violation issues
with the house rules and I don't want to
do that but if if if the Democrat Caucus
was comfortable that we were not leaving
anyone behind as we went forward that
would be that would be good
okay
super
um
okay so so to take us to the next step I
think I said you know we are working on
House Bill 49. the amendment that
representative Wallner gave to us last
week is a is a an amendment to house
bill 49. what
um we will be looking at sb1 in full
Finance tomorrow and it's going to be
coming to us as a division three work
session later tomorrow
so what we say on today on House Bill 49
and the amendment I view it as the dress
rehearsal for what we're going to end up
doing with sb1 because it's clear from
Communications with the Senate that the
vehicle they want us to send them back
is sb1 it's easier for them to deal with
so so so you know I'm sorry for the
confusion what we are talking about HB
49 formally and officially but but this
is really to help us get rapidly to a
resolution tomorrow when sb1 becomes a
work session product for division three
um
now just just to clean up one stray
thought
is that on the assumption that some of
the excellent work that's in sb1 uh gets
onto The Cutting Room floor to use the
film analogy all of those issues can be
considered and potentially incorporated
into House Bill 2 with a house bill one
a dollar amount allocated to to support
what we put into house bill too so so so
even even those things that we don't
keep an sb1 are not dead they're not
dead letters because we're gonna we're
obviously days away from having the
governor's budget and so we'll continue
to talk about about it so those those
issues are not dead the the the
um I think the issue is that we're we're
trying to use the metaphor less is more
we we want to we want to keep something
kind of tight uh that really represents
uh what's critical given the one March
deadline
and I would ask us to apply our judgment
so that we maybe include enough stuff to
sweeten the pot for the Senate to
increase the propensity of them
concurring with our changes it's totally
a subjective thing that's independent
thinking on all your parts
so
um so with with that I I can I can go
back to zero three one one which is the
walner amendment that we talked about
last Friday
yes ma'am I just have a little technical
question I'm trying to pull up sb1 so I
can just have it on my laptop and
perhaps Mr Ripple can help me the um
I have I'm in the docket it says as
amended by the Senate and as amended by
the Senate second version I don't see
anything as passed by the Senate can you
just verify which one I should be
looking at
second thank you I apologize for the
interruption
that's a good question uh and and it's
the second version they got uh past 24
to nothing and uh and and we'll end up
talking about a couple of key things
that was done uh in that in order to get
the unanimity of uh support for it so
um so so representative walner because
we're gonna
open today's in-depth discussions with
your Amendment do you I I know that
you're
busy but but I wanna I wanna respect
your ability to say what you want about
you got a button
when we left here I thought
I did not read draft this amendment I
saw this as sort of a working Amendment
uh because as we talked about it there
were other things that came up
particularly uh Mr ripson talked about
needing some funds to get to the end of
June some additional funds so that
wasn't in the original Amendment so the
amendment is pretty straightforward it
um would move the closing date to June
we'd move it to June 30 2025 and I just
sort of
grabbed that as a
time I didn't know how long it would
really actually take to finish the
construction
um and it appropriated
two million dollars for site evaluation
architectural cons consultation and
development of a design
and then
not included in that but we talked about
it was needing 100 1.5 million for
operating funds to get them through to
June 30th
so okay so everything you said I is
accurate in my view and and just to kind
of make the point this is going to be a
working conversation with the idea that
when we're done uh we'll have given Mr
Ripple more than enough notes to go work
with OLS to come up with a a draft or
excuse me a um an amendment for us and
that when we come back in our working
session tomorrow with with hope and luck
and all good speed we should have an
I I I'm gonna ask him to go ahead and
have an identical copy
readied for sb1
so that when we get into our work
session
we'll have talked about all of this
stuff today there'll be no surprises but
if we like what we've done
we're in a position to immediately act
on sb1 as it's been assigned to us by
the by the by the chair representative
Weiler
is that confusing or is that clear if if
the if the division three members
understand what we're doing then I
okay all right so
um to two line seven
um Mr Ripple and and everyone on a zero
three one one the walner amendment I'll
just call it the walner amendment from
now on
um this is uh down to line 12 an
appropriation of two million dollars for
them to go do site evaluation
architectural Consulting and design
development design options for the
replacement Center one of the things we
talked about last week that I think this
paragraph needs to have included in it
is some language to
direct Das to give us two distinct
options
and and the and the and right now it's
just implying that there's going to be
one option for the most part but we need
two distinct options one option would be
uh this a six to twelve
range
and uh in in brainstorming this
yesterday with representative hole there
was a possibility he might try to his
shot at writing some language in that
regard did you do that representative
thank you I did not I spoke with Mr
Ripple and asked that we work out
something for language but to take each
whatever Amendment 0311 which is
just referred to as the walner amendment
and add in
the necessary costs to continue
operation of the sununu center
um through the balance of this budget
cycle knowing that hb2 and hb1 one step
at a time I know right now we're just
talking about the design money and we'll
get we'll get to the operations money
we'll do that so I have asked that Mr
Ripple craft something and we'll figure
out how to make that such that after the
design phase or the conceptual design
phase but before the detailed design
phase that there is some review back
with either fiscal or House and Senate
Finance combined not sure how to make
that process work yes so so based on
that feedback Miss Ripple do you think
that you have enough information to
create an enlightened addition to this
paragraph so that we're getting the two
I think so I think I would just need to
know exactly which committees you want
the two designs to go to and whether you
want those committees to
review the designs or approve one of the
two designs
that's a really good question and I I
have my answer to that
um I I'm going to ask representative
Weiler if uh if if if if if he'll if
he'll listen in on this and give it his
input I I I think that we wanted to
um at least go back to the Joint
legislative fiscal committee
I would think that we would want the
joint legislative fiscal committee to
exercise
the authority to approve or disapprove
of the design because there may be the
release of additional money to begin the
build part of the construction
I would want as a courtesy to give HHS
oversight a copy of the committee of
that report I would also think children
and family law should I I just don't
know how detailed to get into this
whether we should just be giving it to
the speaker into the Senate and the
governor and just and not worry about
distribution Beyond The Joint
legislative fiscal committee I I'll take
guidance
my view is we're two years behind
because of what happened
in the last budget and we didn't go
ahead and do anything
and what we're seeing from the director
is a continuing decrease in population
and we heard from uh representative Kirk
who's also given this quite a bit of
attention that yes
likelihood is that it will be a smaller
building than what some of these things
and the most important thing is that we
change the March first deadline that's
all that's important all the rest of
this I think we're moving too fast and
I'm not ready to to start designing a
new building until we get some idea
we're already as I said we're two years
behind so we're we're way behind on
where we should be and and I think
you're trying to make it move a little
faster but I'm not sure we're ready for
that uh
that's my opinion that we should try to
see if the if the forecast is that the
population will continue to shrink we
may need to look at it for a couple of
years and see is that is that the
instance or
do we need more so I'm not so sure we
know what to do with it representative
um well I'm kind of the new guy uh here
and then in in this process and didn't
uh struggle through the the last
budgetary cycle I've been kind of
listening uh to some of the preliminary
uh information meetings we've had and
um uh you know my my initial reaction uh
was
um you know you know first of all New
Hampshire relies heavily on contractors
we talked about our four 400 contractors
and we have extensive processes to
assure quality and efficiency using that
kind of a mechanism unlike most states
in the area and
um you know applying my kind of my
general uh
um business background and listen
listening uh to what I heard here
um you know we had
you know somewhat relieved we only had
15 job attrition in the last last few
months we have 60 percent uh vacancies
uh in jobs I guess 28 out of 45
positions and uh trying to make a major
major decision about
um you know what kind of a replacement
Center uh there could be uh I know in in
you know when when a brand name or or
certain type of service gets a bad
reputation it can be really really
difficult uh to turn it around
um and you know could take 20 years and
one slip up and we're back where we are
again because of what's happened in this
case uh here so
um uh and you know I I was quite taken
by uh representative Kirk's comments and
as uh chairman Weiler just mentioned
that um uh uh you know I'm in line to
take a deep breath but even I even think
we should go back and consider
the idea of you know the make make
versus build model of whether we could
do a better job for these kids and for
our taxpayers perhaps Contracting out
these Services rather than even building
a new facility let alone designing it
and coming up with the ideal size
again you know this this is just mine
coming in uh you know as a totally
totally New Perspective on this only
only really following this in the last
um thank you for that I I think you
opened up a a second issue beyond what I
was trying to get us to focus on which
is just simply
um
if we go and ask for design
recommendations
who should review them and approve them
and and and and I and I still think
I I agree with what is in the Wallner
um the Assumption that's built into the
Wallner amendment that we should go
ahead and appropriate some money now for
these designs to begin because as what
was mentioned we've already kind of
wasted two years
and to pick up on the vacancy issue
we're already having trouble recruiting
and retaining uh and and I think we're
just in a situation
where I'm starting to fear an employee
collapse of the system if we if we can't
if we can't
start doing something on offense and if
we continue to look as though the
legislature is never going to get around
to solving this decades-old problem I'm
just concerned
that we're going to break the break what
we got completely and and what we'd
really like to do is we'd like to have
them start implementing this therapeutic
model
we we had testimony last week that as
much as the department would like to
implement the therapeutic model that
children and family law has said
repeatedly over the terms is essential
to the future of how we take care of
these kids
that we we just can't do it unless we
stabilize our employment situation and
we give the department the the room to
breathe to hire and start training and
retraining the their people to begin the
new approaches and so so my fear if we
if we don't
signal that we're going to move forward
it just it's just going to keep hurting
these kids I think we're hurting kids at
this point
representative Waller what do you what
what do you think this is your Amendment
and you've got the appropriation of 2
well I think that we're getting close to
when we're going to see the budget
next week we're going to have the budget
and we're going to start the budget
process
really historically I think that the way
this would be dealt with what it does
have I mean the Senate Bill won not
not 49 but Senate Bill won
um does have a fairly large
appropriation in it It's Not Unusual for
the finance committee to
um hold money bills and as and you do
them as we're doing the budget
and to me at this point I have to say I
agree with representative Weiler that
maybe we hold on here
put the date out and make sure that
people understand that it's not not
going to close immediately I mean it's
not going to close on March 1st and we
um
take a look a real
hard look at this during the budget
process and see how much needs to be
appropriated some
this was my Amendment from last week was
strictly a draft of a work you know some
I think it was brilliant though and I
preferred it to where we are right now
so uh representative hole did you do you
have comments or thoughts on this I do
pushing out the deadline by although
it's to whatever two years plus from now
right pushes it into the next into this
budget cycle at a minimum
effectively the house will have a budget
in less than seven weeks or our side of
it so if we've moved it out and funded
operations through the balance of this
biennium
um the law the potential loss of
personnel is addressed we know we have
to fund this anyway in a budget
we're going to be doing that working
concurrently on that so A simple
amendment that just funds operations
through the end of the year
um at the 1.5 or 1.6 requested by the
department
um gets us there
and that may not be what the Senate is
interested in but at least it eliminates
the issue at hand which is closure
whatever three and a half weeks from now
and I think that's what everybody is is
thinking about and gives us time to do
due diligence on this because it is a
different legislature there are some
different views on how many people
should be the facility should be planned
for and what is the appropriate
um policies regarding incarceration
versus training versus whatever
so so I'm I'm trying to chunk this out
and I'm still just dealing with the
Chunk on line seven through twelve on
the appropriation of the two million
dollars what I'm hearing is a sense of
the committee that we don't really want
to do that we want to go ahead and pull
out appropriation out and and and not
direct the site evaluation and design to
begin after all because we think we can
do this in hb2 when we've not been able
to do it in the last five attempts but
somehow in the calm
non-pressure of the hb2 process we're
going to finally achieve resolution of
something that's been lost to us for a
decade that that's what I hear the sense
to be
um and I I will defer the cumulative guy
experience here certainly outweighs mine
it it doesn't that does not feel like a
good plan to me I I would like to
advocate for us to keep this
appropriation in there for uh to go
ahead and initiate the design
under two models kind of a small model a
middle model and so that so that when we
come back in January we actually have
some information that we keep saying we
don't have so I I I that that's what I'd
like to do so so so I think I we agree
that that the first part of the walner
amendment to kick this out all the way
through the next fiscal year the closing
of the next fiscal year is the right
thing to do we all agree on that is
there anyone who disagrees with kicking
it out to the end of the next fiscal
year no what I wanted to talk about the
name of it Escapes Me Now Keith and I
were discussing it a program starting
with the younger kids
that perhaps prevents them from getting
into trouble when they get to be 14 15
16. we start with the 11 12 13 years old
maybe
what's the name of it system of care
okay come on up uh and if you can also
be prepared to tell us the numbers that
you do have
um because I think that was one of your
homework assignments I mean it's almost
too soon to see the results of that
program but if that program has the
capacity to reduce this population then
we have to deal with that
good morning everybody Joe ripsom
director dcyf good to see everyone
um so where would you like me to start
with the budget numbers or with let's
address representative Weiler's issue uh
about the system of care uh giving the
system to restate it I think the the
question is
[Music]
um
do we do we believe that if we can as we
continue to mature and develop the
system of care model that that system of
care model with the earlier
community-based interventions do we
believe that will have a positive impact
on reducing the potential
detainee and committed populations in
sununo
the the Democratic demographics we've
seen for three years is pretty steady at
ranging from 12 to 18.
just just system of care do we have hope
that the system of care changes will
will drop that number further yep so the
data that I passed around I know the
first sheet looks familiar there's two
sheets in this that are not familiar to
you that start to tell this story so and
starts to answer the question of that
yes the system of care is one already
having an impact and yes I do think it's
going to have a longer term impact all
that being said
we are already I'll repeat already the
lowest combined rate of detention and
commitment in the country there is no
precedent anywhere else in the nation
for having a lower level than we
currently have right so the idea that
three years of study data is going to
change in the next two years I'm a
little skeptical about right I think we
actually have a pretty good data set to
make decisions on that being said I do
hope that what we're seeing right now is
the system of care having its impact on
the older youth to the extent that it
can when the system of care really
starts churning that's when it starts
getting those 10 and 11 year olds today
that don't turn into the 16 and 7 year
olds 16 17 year olds that show up in
these facilities
you're talking another seven ten years
down the road you might see the need
drop by another number of kids but I
don't think you're going to eliminate
the need for a secured facility so let
me walk folks through this data just to
kind of explain what we're seeing in the
system I'm going to ask a clarification
and and a data check last week I think
he showed up saying that we were second
best in the nation today you were your
second best test second best detention
we are behind Maine who claims to have
zero detained kids which I'm skeptical
about they do have a program they call
shock incarceration which I think is
just another word for detention but it
makes them categorize it as commitment
which would make us number one attention
we are second best in commitment behind
Connecticut when you add up
Connecticut's two numbers and means two
numbers we are lowest overall so the
lowest combined rate of detention and
commitment is what I would say but if
you're measuring them as individual
we're second to Maine
okay so that's really good yes and then
to the other point I think you
qualitatively suggested that we could
have an improvement still
with system of care matures
but but I kind of need a number if we're
if we're if we've been ranging between
12 to 18 what's your professional
judgment telling us are we 10 to 12 are
we where do you think this is going
because because we're being asked to
look into the future in a crystal ball
what's your crystal ball telling you
it's really really hard for me to tell
you that right and then there's other
variables that we don't have right now
that we don't know right you could have
major changes in our demographics that
that change you know what what we see in
terms of crime and criminal Behavior you
could have
rapid you know increases in in different
type of criminal and gang activities
that we don't currently see much of
right now in New Hampshire right so
there's other Dynamics Beyond just this
that could happen into the future that
could change some of this that being
said right right now we've been
averaging 12 we Crest at 18. we bought
them out at five at times
and you know but through all of that the
idea is that you still when an average
of 12 you need flexibility within your
building we don't want any more kids
there than we need and I think our
history shows that we don't have a
history of over utilizing the facility
right I have 144 beds today and if
there's only five kids that need to be
there then only five kids are in that
building right we're not trying to fill
this building up but the 18 beds would
give flexibility to make sure that
you're able to even if we are at a point
where we only needed eight
that you're able to separate kids based
on gender based on criminal activity
based on
gang affiliations based on behavioral
challenges between them so I I guess you
know my my belief is that the 18 beds
really is not an excessive number and
isn't a reason for us to not move
forward with this because at the end of
the day all you're really getting is
some extra flexibility to allow us to
have appropriate separation of kids at
times based on their needs
but with that I'm happy to go into the
data oh
go ahead and hit this data sure so we
talked about this last time right you do
see around 2018 two things happened at
once right the system of care SB 14 at
the time passes big investment happens
at that time with the system of care
coming up at the same time changes in
our laws around detention and commitment
and who could be detained and committed
happens so you see this big collapse of
who's going into sysc
now
if what all that happened in the system
right because I think we heard testimony
last week that that change in law was
the only thing that made the difference
right I I think last week former chair
Kirk suggested that that's the big thing
that's happened and that we could change
all of this just by
changing the law again
and I want to make sure that people are
clear that that's not the only thing
that's happening here
if that's what if that was the only
thing that happened you would expect
that these kids that used to be at sysc
would show up in non-secured programs
right they'd show up in residential
you see you know we used to hover around
200 Justice involved kids in residential
care
and you do see it it makes a jump when
that law change happens when sysc stops
taking so many kids and then you see it
start to go down
right you see a big jump here around
2020 with covet and I'll talk about that
in a minute but you see this downward
Trend happening long before covid this
is the system of care starting to work
with kids and starting to get Kids
community-based Care
so it's already having an impact not
just at sysc but also in the residential
system and actually really serving kids
in the community where they need to be
which is an amazing thing that we should
all be really really proud of
um what you see down here I like to be a
little bit careful to not claim that
this 100-ish level in residential which
is the current level of kids in juvenile
justice in residential care that is
somewhat suppressed artificially by
Workforce issues at residential programs
right so I don't want to claim that this
is the the new status quo because the
real demand is probably slightly higher
than where this is but the new status
quo is probably somewhere lower
than here because what's been happening
at the same time is what you see on the
the next page of the data with the
flagship program of the children's
system of care
so the flagship program of the system of
care is something that we call fast
forward it's a high fidelity wraparound
program for young people to work for
young people and their families to work
with the team the teams led by a
clinical person they bring together
everybody who's important to that kid
and family clinicians who are working
with them the schools
other family members grandparents and
uncles members of the faith community
whoever it is that's important to that
kid and family and they also put in-home
clinicians in the home to start working
with the kids they connect the adults
with peer support through Nami New
Hampshire and they connect the kids with
peer support as well so that the kids
have somebody to talk to about the
challenges they're facing with you know
having mental health challenges
you'll see here they're serving close to
500 kids right I'm not claiming that
every kid at sysc is showing up here
instead that's not what this is this
system serves kids with Behavioral
Health Care needs across the Spectrum
including the Juvenile Justice
population but not exclusive to the
Juvenile Justice population right so
that's why these numbers aren't going to
be a one for one shift that's not what's
happening here but they are absorbing
tons of these kids that used to be in
residential care and used to be at sysa
so all that's to say to answer chair
Wyler's question that yes the system of
care is having an impact today it's
critical that we continue to support and
invest that into the future because it's
going to keep having an impact my
experience running a comparable system
in New Jersey tells me that it will
continue to have an impact over time
but I'm really really cautious that when
we're already the lowest detention and
commitment in the country that we can
start to bank further reductions and
that what you're really talking about is
the difference between building a few
bedrooms on a facility that otherwise is
going to be comparable
right so the savings of building a few
bedrooms is
not all that significant and then that
leads into the conversation about the
costs that we can get into in a minute
but as I said last time the real savings
if we're talking from Strictly an
economic perspective from my view is the
savings of moving to a shared services
model like that's where we're going to
actually
reduce the cost of sysc that's been
operating on an island for a hundred and
forty years
right and now when it's operating on an
island serving 12 kids where you have to
run 24 7 nursing in a separate
commercial kitchen and all this other
stuff it makes no sense
right you put that same program next to
a Hampstead or next to a New Hampshire
hospital where you can share those
services and your operational costs are
going to go down by a couple million
plus a year and that's going to be the
savings right worrying about the couple
million you're going to spend on five
extra bedrooms
doesn't seem to be
the uh the the biggest worry when every
single year there's a general fund
savings of two to three million out
there that we're gonna waste because
we're worried about saving two millions
in arpa to to prevent us from building
five bedrooms
so I'm gonna put some words in your
mouth and and and and if they're not
comfortable they're just you know change
them what what what I think I heard you
say
is that yes system of care has been
delivering it's likely to continue to
deliver but that we're never going to
get to the point where we're at zero
there's always going to be some kids
that need this level of physical
security
um we've committed to closing the
existing facility which means we need to
have some kind of a replacement facility
that that that's where we're at we we
you you aren't prepared to tell us what
that number of the capacity of that
but it sounds like you're kind of
comfortable with a maximum of 18. yeah
yeah that's right you know when we look
at the data for the past three years 18
has been kind of the high water mark and
that's been rare but we do need
flexibility for operational reasons
right so that's that's where we get to
the 18 number it's not that we
anticipate 18 kids being there regularly
it's that we need to have mostly
flexibility for kids and on the rare
occasion that we hit that high water
mark we we need to have the op the
ability to to meet the demand so so if
we do not put the appropriation to have
the department go out to start doing
some design planning inside evaluation
if we don't put it into this budget Bill
put it into the budget that's probably
at least a four-month delay in having
you start that work correct is there any
value in delaying having that design
work done it's going to have to get done
is it not I don't think there's any
value in delaying any of this is my
opinion right we're we're at a point
that if we want to be able to use the
federal ARP dollars we're really at the
end of the time frame to hit go
we wasted a year not doing anything
because we couldn't come to agreement
last session
and that was already going to be
ambitious at this point we're really at
the end so if we want to use those
resources instead of general fund
resources for this purpose we really
need to hit go as soon as possible if on
the other hand we don't care about that
then I guess we can wait so so I made a
statement before you took you came up it
said I fear
that a lack of action can lead to an
employment collapse at the sununu center
is that just hand ringing and
fear-mongering on my part what to what
extent is that a rational concern I
think it's already we've already
experienced that
and the people that are left you know I
begged and pleaded and cajoled to stick
around promising that there's relief on
the way that there's a future you know
and and the process and pointing to
these every newspaper article talking
about you know when when former chair
umberger said we're not going to let
this place close in a few months I
walked into the facility and I showed
them that newspaper article say look
like you're going to have a job you know
and when the Senate passed that
billionaires really I walked in there
and I showed them that you know and that
gets people to say okay and we've
actually been able to start having some
productive interviews with people who
you know typically interviewing this am
I going to have a job if I take this and
you know when we can point to those
newspaper articles that gives us some
some ability to convince people that
they have a future if they take a job
with us but no if we don't have a plan
if we're in limbo
so so just to make it explicit tell us
what the so what factor is so so what if
we if we approve this appropriation for
design inside evaluation now and instead
of four months
so what what what difference will that
make to you and your ability to run this
mission
well I think certainly if if this is
going to be a two-step process if you're
not going to just go forward with sb1 or
something comparable in the short term
then we lose the ability to use ARP
funds for construction that'll be off
were you you've been waiting haven't you
uh then we'll come to you representative
go ahead representative Weiler
um
I just wondered what the um
how much time do we have with the arpa
funds I know there's a time they have to
be committed and then you have to spend
them down what what is that looking like
yeah I'm not I'm not the expert on that
um the governor's budget director came
to the Senate
um finance committee and testified that
it was something around the September
2025 Mark or shortly thereafter but it
beautiful
five
so and that's for completion of the
project
do you know that sounds right yes okay
so the building would have to be
built by then
and we also had Charlie Arley house who
came and talked about the difference
between what's in the bill
which I think is 15 million at Senate
bill one and what he sort of anticipated
the actual cost would be
so I'm assuming we can't get additional
arpa money
so would that be General funds that we
would be looking at
so I I don't know the answer to that
because I don't know what's available in
arpa beyond the 15 million there could
be additional beyond that but 15 was
what was put aside for this project
based on the the 15 million came from
the estimates that were given by Das
back at the original committee that that
representative Edwards is the only
surviving member of
the other four members are no longer in
in the legislature
um but that that committee received an
estimate at that time of 15 million of
course since that time we have seen
major changes in inflation Workforce
labor costs and everything else yielding
what was the higher estimate
um I did get an answer on your other
question about the arpa funds
um
it needs to be obligated by 12 31 24 and
needs to be I'm sorry
spent
by 12 31 26 is what my colleague here is
telling me
okay so that's
considerably
longer amount of time to spend them yeah
we need to be obligated by 12 31 24 so I
guess that would mean you'd have to have
a contract with the construction company
by then okay so if the process was you
know a two-year design process waiting
for
you know an approval of which way to go
that would make that very difficult but
great thank you
thank you Mr I have three questions from
Mr ribson that that's okay
so the first ones I get hopefully an
easy one regarding the output funds do
we know those funds can be used to build
a prison that is um I didn't do that
analysis but the folks at uh gopher
which I remember I'm not remembering
what that stands for but I think
everybody in here knows what gopher is
um they've they've done that analysis
and said yes okay could you just get us
that information that you know actual
hard copy that says a lawyer said we can
do this
um I'd really appreciate that
um then two questions related to the
changing of the date and Staffing
so specifically regarding just sort of
keeping the staff
my understanding from your previous
testimony was one of the issues has been
that we're talking March 1st so
everybody's bailing out but now we're
talking basically the end of the next
biennium which is a significant which we
could even go further if you feel that's
necessary but wouldn't just having a two
plus year extension tell the staff that
we are going that they still have jobs
it's not like the thing is going to
close suddenly underneath their feet it
would certainly be better than the
status quo absolutely be better than the
status quo I think what would be best
would be to show that we actually have a
vision for the future and a pathway for
the future but it would be better than
the status quo and the last question is
kind of related to that and you and I
have talked about this a little bit
regarding the trauma informed
therapies
um you indicated a big part of the
problem so related right now this sudden
enclosure was that people didn't get the
people to do it because it was going to
be closing but again with that longer
time period to work with couldn't this
trauma-informed process begin with in
the existing facility knowing that
eventually it would be transformed or
transferred as well to the new facility
understanding that new facility will be
better yeah I mean it's possible right
it's all dependent upon our ability as I
said last time to secure a steady stable
Workforce so if in fact that is that's
enough to help us secure a steady stable
Workforce then yes it would be possible
for us to start implementing those new
programs
oh thank you thank you Mr chair
representative Mooney you had a question
quite a while ago did you get it
addressed
thank you I know I didn't it was
bringing it back to the discussion of
where plans would go upon designs and my
thought and I'm trying to keep track
here of all the outstanding issues we
have floating in the room so at a point
uh appropriate I'd like to make that as
one of my points like you
all right so
um
so I would like
to make my request
to the division and then we'll go on go
around and and hear what you think
because Mr Ripple needs to take notes
and and make an amendment
I am going to ask
for you to support
keeping this Appropriations language for
the design and side evaluation in the
amendment that we produce now
and I I think
that that is a good thing to do because
it's inevitable in any ways to to get
this design and a side evaluation
process started we've heard the
department say that the the co-location
shared services is a good model to
reduce operating costs over the long run
we're going to see some numbers on that
I I think uh that yes if we kick the can
down the road through the next fiscal
year that will help some uh to to to for
their employment situation
but I I can't help but to think that
from a morale perspective if they know
that we're actually going to start to do
the work that we've been talking about
for a decade of planning what the future
looks like that that says something that
a mere delay does not say so so I am I'm
asking for your support on continuing to
have
the essence of this paragraph on the
appropriation for the design and build
in it and so
um that's my request
yes or no uh representative Weiler
I'll support it how much money do you
want to have the design
um we've got two million in here this
was a straight up design since then
we've kicked around the idea of two
designs a small and a medium and so I
don't know if two million still passes
that sanity check but but that that that
that's the amount that's in there yes
sir yeah we've got it already on paper
let's go with it representative walner
yes let's leave the design money and
thank you so much uh do you want to wait
or do you want to say now representative
pilersky I just wanted to comment didn't
we hear last week for Mr arlinghaus that
that is an appropriate amount he said he
thought it would be 1.8 1.9
you know that's an excellent memory when
it was just a single design he said 1.6
is the number he shared yes good point
so so 2 million ought to be yeah I'm
just clarifying that yes
good point yeah I am after hearing the
timeline of the arpa funds I think I
would um want to see what we could do to
get going
so so that's that's yes okay
representative Hull
yes and I think we're back to rep what
representative Mooney was discussing
which is if they have two conceptual
designs who and when they are shared is
something that still needs to be worked
out I have no issues with kicking them
off to do the work
this is a fairly significant thing to do
sending it just through fiscal may not
be the right solution I don't know what
the timing is to have two conceptual
designs done but I would like to see the
two conceptual designs come back for
review maybe the the languages they sent
are sent to the house speaker and the
Senate President and the house senate
house speaker and Senate President
determine how that information is shared
in their respective bodies
we will come back to that I just gotten
yes or no at this point representative
erf
I'm very uncomfortable with uh doing
something with so many
questions still outstanding and find it
hard to believe that a four-month delay
is
the end of the world I mean if the whole
committee wants to go along with this
I'll go along but I think it's not
necessary and short-sighted
um especially given that we have so many
members of not only our committee but
the HHS committee which presumably will
now have a chance to look at this the
bigger picture now over the coming
months who are new members and don't
have the same kind of background depth
of background that a number of us have
to hear from workout and me only for a
few terms but others for decades
apparently
um so if the senses to go along I'll go
along but um but I think it's not a good
idea
okay for the purposes of the Strava I'll
just think of you as a no I I I want to
answer
um the point uh this this has been with
children and family law not HHS and I
know you know that my apologies uh but
uh they have had their batting practice
on hb120 and hb120 ended up getting
amended in children and family law to
include
um an amendment that makes it look
identical to the sentence version that
got passed of sb1
they've been asked to retain HP 120. I
had an opportunity to speak with their
Vice chair yesterday and said hey so
what do you think about hb120 you know
you got some new new people over there
uh what do you think and he says he
thinks it would have passed uh if they
had gotten the committee to do it he
thinks he's lost about four people but
otherwise it would have passed with an
OTP a recommendation on a committee but
it's been retained yes sir
may I respond yes uh thank you Mr chair
I understand that um I know
representative long as well
it's not an issue of whether it would
have passed or not passed I think it was
I went to the hearing um and actually I
didn't I was kind of surprised that I
don't think that actually voted enough
committee yet
um but my concern was sitting at that
meeting that yes the people might vote
for it but that doesn't mean that they
feel they're informed I mean I've sat
through this for several terms and I
still learn new things so I'm I'm
skeptical not only the people on that
committee but on ours who are new that
they really have a depth of knowledge of
what we're talking about here and the
trade-offs uh going forward thank you
Fair Point uh or for this acquisition
money do you think you're a yes or no
not there yet but uh I'm moving along
and I think I need to
um you know I'm just very concerned that
we're we're moving towards a center that
uh uh is going to adopt uh the
reputational uh challenges that come
with the existing Center and there may
actually be other ways to support these
families and these kids without a new a
new facility let alone deciding the
exact size so you're holding out a
belief that one of the options that will
other than extending the system of care
maybe or something
yeah perhaps and okay I'm sure I could
be brought up to to speed some more and
and talk with the commissioner but uh
um yeah I still have a few questions and
whether the two million would be well
spent or not thank you thank you thank
you just a comment yes sir
the group that evaluates proposed
construction is not the fiscal committee
it's the Public Works committee
they have a lot of experience at doing
this and looking at buildings and that's
what they do the whole uh hb25 comes
from their analyzes so this would be in
that that would be the place this would
go that and governor and Council will
also look at construction contracts
fiscal committee doesn't doesn't look at
construction contracts
I I am so glad you gave me a an
authentic Dodge to get out of this issue
here in the very near term
representative Moody that answers my
question thank you representative Weiler
got it so now it's to you yes or no on
the acquisition money on two million
dollars is the question on yes I'm good
with that okay and so am I so so let's
go ahead uh Miss Ripple and include that
in the fresh Amendment
um and then on the issue this is a
little tiny issue and hopefully we can
just zip now that we've done this once
um
I I think we need to go ahead and put in
there that we want two options we want
the six to twelve we want the 12 to 18
because I think those are going to look
different
um
so what what do you say to that
representative Weiler
yeah it's a good thing and by the time
that's done we may have some more
experience in which progress and how
it's moving and I think Mr ribs has a
pretty good handle on it what's
happening and like he says we're the
lowest
so things are happening well maybe it's
the population we have uh we just think
I hope they don't keep sending MS-13
members to our state uh thank you
representative walner yes or no on the
two designs
you know that that's not the most
important thing to me right now the most
important thing to me is I'd really like
to hear
I would like to see the site evaluation
and where it's going to be to me is what
I would like to if I were going to
prioritize what we would do first I
think
coming down to the point of where we're
going to do
this building is more important right
now to me so we just appropriated that
money though in the amendment right so
it's going to take months and we're
probably not going to see it till
January but in the meantime when they
show up in January should they show up
with with two two designs
probably on the same sites it's this is
not affecting the site evaluation this
is this is affecting you know the
options of the next legislature has well
it could affect the site evaluation I
mean it could affect it I mean one site
might not be large enough to put in an
18 bed and another site might I mean
depends on where I don't know where
these building sites are at this point
yeah so are you a yes or no on the two
sites uh evaluations
two designs I want to hear what Mr
ripson's has no go ahead sure so um as
we said before there's three possible
sites that are being considered one
would be to remain on the current campus
which obviously has some disadvantages
both from right the the awful history
that associated with that campus and
um with the fact that you wouldn't have
a shared services model being able to be
effectuated on that campus you wouldn't
have those the benefits that you would
get the other two options that have been
considered are within proximity to New
Hampshire hospital or within proximity
to Hampstead Hospital because those two
sites you'd be able to have a shared
services model and those two sites offer
somewhat different ability to share
Services
certainly things like you know
facilities laundry food those things
both options give you the opportunity
for shared services for things like
Clinical Services and education at
nursing too you could share across both
of those but for things like Clinical
Services and education you'd get more
opportunity at a site like Hampstead
because they serve you know a youth
population in a way that they don't
currently serve a New Hampshire hospital
but there is work that is anticipated to
be done through the through the contract
with the design firm to look at the
sites and ensure that we have you know
an appropriate place to to to do that
you know to put a building for that
purpose
yeah and how long do you think the site
evaluation at what point do you think
you'll be ready with saying where you
so we've you know as I've said before we
did start with no contracts are signed
yet but we did start the process
um with Public Works to try to identify
an architect and design firm and that
part of that contract was to help us
with the site evaluation work that's one
of the first parts of the design process
but I I don't remember in the timeline
that was proposed what the what the
timeline was for the site evaluation
component of it but the goal was to have
that ready to go as soon as we were
given the funding and authority to to do
so from this body and the governor
okay thank you look I'd like to continue
going around the table just to get yes
or no on the two design versus One
Design but do you represent while or do
you want to say something now I just
wanted to add one of the little
surprises that come about sometime
before the present Youth Center was
built
I was had a tour of the uh the dcyf
seems like the meals were catered and
brought in to each living unit and there
was several different units
so now we open this this Center and the
whole thing was oh we didn't have to
worry about the security and moving from
building to building and have security
so we can have them all in one building
where they can't jump away and run out
so we go and we said first thing we said
so what did we save
D oh sorry
it's more expensive to operate
why is that well now we have a kitchen
and we have to have staff there 18 hours
a day which we never had before
and so why didn't they figure this in
you know this is the thing that disturbs
me that
I don't know what they were paying for
the meals brought in but when you have
four or five people there 18 hours a day
that was that was quite a big change in
cost and I used one you still have with
all those all that kitchen for the low
population so we've got to think of
these things that's why it's important
to have the shared services
so you know we don't have the this
kitchen set up to feed 140 people and
now it's feeding a lot less so that's
one of the things I just it's one of the
things I recall that was surprised they
hadn't calculated this in
uh thank you for that uh representative
honestly I don't think I
have enough knowledge to actually speak
to that because I don't have this is the
one place you get to abstain I I think I
would abstain although I will I will say
that the the lack of the site at this
point is concerning to me also
um because I feel like we're just
shooting in the dark not knowing where
we're going so to hear that
it sounds like one of those sites is
potentially eliminated if we're talking
about the sununu center
then I guess that makes me
a little more comfortable
um but I do feel like we're
deciding something that we're not sure
where it's going and I would really love
more of a staged approach
but I at this point will I will back off
from giving a commitment to the beds
so let me ask this question then do you
do you know if there's any uh geography
limitations that's not the right word
but uh could could we build an 18
bed facility near the New Hampshire
hospital because they they have swamp
issues and not a lot of buildable land
is a is that even is to I think
representative Waller brings up the
point we got to worry about the site
well if one of those sites can't support
an 18 bed facility because of the
location then then that does sort of
start to limit what we might see in the
future yeah and I I don't know the
answer to that right the the state
office campus you know there's there are
there's land around there but the
viability of all that land and there's
also unused buildings around there that
may be the space of those buildings are
ought to be appropriate space as well so
that's part of what the site review
process would be looking at
okay uh representative hole the one one
design or two designs
I would be in favor of two
uh representative
I've more points to make based on this
well this is really the point we have a
whole raft of questions that are just
coming up right here in this short
meeting that we've had and let's start
there I agree with representative
solorski I think the Department's
already eliminated the sonuna site and I
don't have a problem with that but that
was pretty clear when a moment ago he
said we these shared services are a big
part of the cost savings which says to
me we've also eliminated New Hampshire
hospital because they also just recently
said that essentially the best cost
savings will be achieved at the at the
Hampstead Hospital site
also I'm is Public Works going to then
be deciding whether we go with a 6 to 12
or a 12 to 18 is that part of this is
that how this citing thing is is working
out
um so I I
I'm just frustrated that this we have
all these questions that are coming up
from around the committee room and here
we are saying well we'll just throw two
million dollars in and get the ball
rolling thank you
I don't think so so I'm a yes I'd rather
I'm sorry I should say I'm a yes to your
question because I think we should both
should be considered I don't think this
is the right way to do it all right so
so you're yes to two two two designs and
representative Weiler did you have
something to say I don't think Public
Works would decide
on what the size of it should be they
will decide on things like where it
would be what kind of structure it would
be how it would be built and things like
that but they would look at the proposal
they would look at the two proposals if
there's two different sizes and say you
know here's what needs to be done on
this one here's what needs to be done on
that one they may be able to give us
some figures of what the final cost
would be but I don't think they would
step in and say this is the one you got
to build not this one I don't think they
would get in at that level they're just
going to evaluate what is proposed
before them
right right I I and I I just would want
to add that um I I feel like I've been
looking at this exact same issue since
the uh the bill came to us two years ago
in division three I mean it's
essentially the same conversation except
we're getting smarter we're getting
deeper but but the terrain of what we're
talking about I think is largely
unchanged uh it's my perspective do you
have a one versus two design
yeah assuming I get there uh get that
far I would say that I would prefer two
to one thank you all right
representative Mooney
absolutely on two I think it's customary
for Architects first of all in their
designs to have multiple options and
second of all we've heard repeatedly
from this gentleman here that 18 is a
reasonable number to go forward so that
has got to be explored thank you thank
you and I'm also a too okay so so that
we've teed this up now a couple times
when they get these designs
how are we going to get to the decision
of build X or build y or build something
totally Z like what what's the process I
I hear we want to do some Public Works
uh pass through to what I I don't know
how to do this I have no clue on how to
do this
we got the expert here
he's looking at what's happening
Nationwide
I don't know that I don't trust that the
president Administration not to be
packing Us full of illegal immigrants
some of which will be gang members let's
stay on topic well that's a possibility
they're being sent all over the country
so we've got to we've got to be aware of
that and here's the expert he's going to
be very attuned to what's happening
and we're going to look at another year
or two of experience and see so one of
the what's the trend what are you seeing
and then he's going to make the decision
of what he thinks is best for us and
it's not going to come down to us it's
going to come down to the experts what's
the real experience what do we need what
is working and that's at that point we
choose so is it who is the we choose is
it I'm I'm trying to interpret what I
think I just heard you say and it
sounded like you implied representative
Weiler that that we would let the
department choose between the design
options and I I don't I don't think
that's what you mean but that's what I
think I heard that's what I mean we
would let the department advise us what
was best okay so they would be in an
advisory role but who would make the
decision I I just want to know who will
make the decision is it the GNC is it is
it is a governor is it who I mean
because I I assume we need to write
something in we're saying we're getting
this data somebody's going to have to do
something with this data the big thing
we need is a decision we make we make
the laws we put it in law
this is what's funded this is what we
oh okay representative Wallner do you
have thoughts on this who decides how to
decide
well I think the legislature decides
we'll make the final decision I don't
really think you leave that up to the
administration to make that decision I
think that's it's a legislative we would
appropriate the funds for whichever
model we went with
and that's a legislative that's our job
um and I don't think we would leave it
up to anyone else where would it where
in your view where would it enter the
legislative process probably have to
come in as a piece of legislation as a
separate piece of legislation imagine it
would would okay now you're going to
have two options
so I think you would probably have to
have some sort of legislation to say
we're picking option A or B
so let's let's get ready to park that
after representative tolerski has her
opportunity to speak
I just have a question that perhaps you
all can answer for me who would be
considered the experts in this
therapeutic approach of care to these
children
is it children and family law is it
Health and Human Services Nelly fairs is
it you guys I'm
who has that knowledge well it's the
department it's in the executive branch
but within the legislature
um uh HHS would probably be better
qualified from an evaluation of the
therapeutic model than any of the other
committees you mentioned children and
family law is interested in the you know
sort of the Child Welfare impacts and
implications we're worried about it from
the financial aspects Public Works is
worried about it from is this the right
construction have we thought of
everything as the bonding right I you
know I don't know what all they do but
so I don't I don't think there's one uh
one answer or or or one committee that
can answer everything but to your
question I think the best qualified is
HHS
foreign
thank you
so look what might come down to
here's the bigger building here's the
smaller building the bigger building is
only a million dollars more
wow
why don't we just go with that then we'd
have room I mean it's going to be a
difference in the costs and all that
sort of thing and from the cost we're
looking at now
I remind us that the original sysc was
built for about 20 million dollars now
we're looking at a
I don't know 12 to 18 bed for the same
price
much smaller building so so what I'd
like to do is I'd like to park this
issue on how we get a decision out of
the legislature because I think later I
want to talk about something that's in
sb1 related to the commission that the
Senate it was important to them and so
when when we get a chance to bring that
back up I think this topic may fit
within that so let's park that
um I think I think we just worked
through the Appropriations issue
um rep or Mr Ripple what would read that
read what you think we've agreed to so
far
uh well so far I think you've agreed to
keep the dates and representative
walner's Amendment or at least that's my
understanding the June 30th 2025. you've
agreed to keep the two million dollar
appropriation uh it sounds like the
members would prefer two options
although what happens with those two
options is yet to be decided
um so that's what I have so far
that's that's a fair summary from my
point of view so so next up let's talk
about the operations money to get from
one March to the end of the fiscal year
I I think the 1.5 million number has
been floated and vetted a few times
um uh you had mentioned 1.6 at one point
just in passing but then you were
comfortable with 1.5 so so what do you
what do you think the real answer is
I am comfortable with 1.5 when I when we
sat down with our fiscal folks the
current shortfall was 1.6 and again that
was because of revenues that we weren't
going to be able to draw in it was
because of overtime burning much higher
than anticipated also because we had a
number of retirements that were
unanticipated when somebody retires the
state has to pay out leave time in a
large lump sum and some of those
employees were very long-term employees
with a lot of banked time so that all
comes out of the budget as well Okay so
we've we've written somewhere Mr Ripple
a paragraph on the 1.5 million I can't
put my fingers on it it's in the bill as
introduced okay can you can you just
grab it and and inherit it into this
amendment yes okay uh that you could do
that is there anyone that disagrees with
the 1.5 additional
okay all right
um
okay so if we were to stop right there
we've achieved success
right I but I don't want to stop right
there and the reason no no no
and and I'll tell you why though I I I
think the Senate
using the committee conference and using
a pretty deliberative process came up
with some elements that they put into
sb1
at least one of them I think was
absolutely critical to getting them the
24 to nothing support and if we're going
to send sb1 back to them
uh and say hey this is what we're going
to do take it or leave it I would at
least like to sweeten the pot a little
bit to show that we know the hard work
that they did
so so I would like to bring your
attention to my Amendment 0 1 9 2.
I I have one do you have one
representative
this should be Amendment Z two yes to
the amendment to HP 49 that's what we're
discussing so this is an amendment to 49
it lay number zero one nine two
okay I would ask you to flip to page
five
and note from lines one
down to 34.
there's a a new subdivision on the
commission to study Public Safety of the
secured Youth Development Center
okay
now what what is this paragraph in terms
of the discussion process
when this was not in sb1
this was not in the First Amendment to
sb1 I'll just refer to casually as the
Carson Amendment to the to the sb1 this
was in the Second Amendment this was
essential to uh to securing the support
of at least two senators that
represented uh Hampstead the Hampstead
area so so
the senate had to work its way through
it and this commission that they said
should be established I I I think is
probably still a good idea
and could help for the next part of the
discussion is what do we do with these
two options later you know maybe this
commission could have some role in that
but I'm going to shut up and give you a
few moments to read lines one through 34
foreign
ER all right I represented Hampstead in
my district for 20 years and now I it's
not in my district but this is uh
representative bird cell's complaint
that I have discussed with her
at the cinema Youth Center
the Manchester police are frequently
called I remember having a conversation
with someone who had been a Manchester
policeman
who had
captured The Runaways if you will and
that was when it was not closed in like
it is now
um
the state police
from Massachusetts are closer than the
State Police from New Hampshire to
Hampstead
and the sheriff is is still like 12
miles away the local police it's not
that big a department
they still have local police but I think
they may still have a part-time Chief
there's about three towns around me that
have part-time Chiefs which isn't a bad
thing but they're not always there every
day so there is some uh but there is
full-time police evidence in the town of
Hampstead
that was her concern did they have
enough manpower if they had to say it
all out search someone's runaway or
three of runaway or something like that
and you know they've they've had people
leave the Hampstead Hospital that
doesn't seem to be that big a deal
it's the same one of the same
populations
so troubled youth
so um I think she's overly concerned
with this but obviously they did this to
get her vote what they want to do is is
get in an evaluation of the
um
of the security of the site
I don't see it as a problem because most
of the commission is
is going to be legislators and we're not
paying them a lot but one of the other
things that we have to remember
that may serve in this group is
last budget we put up a hundred million
dollars for abuses by staff
of the of the children
100 million dollars and now all the
lawyers are foaming at the mouth and
lining up but anyway
what this thing could look into is
what is the what is the um oversight of
the people within this facility to
ensure this never happens again and and
who is who is making sure and what is
what is the type of security within the
system I think that's just as important
as figuring out where the nearest police
department is and hopefully this
commission will work on that because we
don't want to have a repeat of what
we've gone through thank you
okay so the topic that I'm I'm trying to
have us focus on is do we want to lift
this language from Amendment
0192 lines 1 through 34 and include it
and
um I'm still going to call it the walner
amendment for now
um and maybe maybe this needs to be
tweaked to be as inclusive as
representative Weiler just suggested but
but uh but I but I want to get the sense
of the of the division on whether it
adds value to include this language and
I I propose it does I think they've got
some good things to be looking at in
parallel there's an ongoing group of
people that can continue to continue to
discuss this
um and and plus we would be reflecting
back a major piece of sb1 to the Senate
to say we listened to you we heard you
this was a good idea we're on board so
so I think that is how we help ourselves
get to yes
so representative walner your thoughts
well again it feels like to me that this
piece goes right back to needing to know
where the site is
um that's
seems to me that's one of the major
things that needs to be decided because
this this is really about Community
involvement
yeah well and it's a but it could be
about Concord
and it might be about Manchester I mean
we don't really know for sure
and maybe no maybe in the end there's
some other place that materializes
um you know I think involving the
communities is a really good idea
um I'm not sure I mean I I would not
object to putting this in
um but I'm not sure we're really ready
because we don't really know how many
commit how many commissions are we going
to have we're going to have three of
them running at the same time
for each site that's a possibility or is
there going to be some decision about
the site by the time this Commission
is in place and I do notice that this
commission and this part of Senate bill
was Senate bill one
um really does also
say that they're going to bring in
legislation
um
oh okay honor before so they're they're
they're anticipating
additional legislation on this matter
um
just to read the line that I I think uh
representative Wallner is accurately uh
citing uh it says the commission shall
submit a preliminary report including
its findings and any recommendations for
proposed legislation so if they don't
have proposed legislation they wouldn't
include it right if they did they would
and that that would be done before uh
the November 1 of 2023 which gives
um the site evaluation design team some
room to work because I think you're
really close to letting that contract
once you have the authority to do it
so so hopefully come September October
there's some information that's going to
be going to this commission if we
establish it for them to
exercise another set of eyes on this
to my my only point was that there you
can see that they're already
anticipating that they would bring in
legislation additional legislation would
come in around the new new sununu center
right
okay so you're you're okay with that I I
could live with this piece being in it
it's really
yeah I don't I don't know that it adds a
lot or doesn't but I like the idea of
communities being involved okay thank
you representative do you want me to
come back to you or do you have an
opinion on this no my only comment was
I'm not sure I'm reading this the same
way that um representative Weiler did in
terms of the commission would have
oversight over the facility the safety
of the facility itself
um and I'm perhaps I just am
misunderstanding how it's being written
but I thought you know I'm reading it as
a community-based public safety
situation
anyone could clarify that I you know
this is why I wouldn't have to
representative Wilder was done talking I
said this would be the bulk of it and
then we could tweak it if we needed to
to make sure it Incorporated is
concerned but but I I think I think
you're you're right that this language
itself does not really bring them to the
task of figuring out Public Safety
within it's it's mostly a coordination
function with the external and knowing
the senator that wanted it in there that
was basically about it wasn't about
within this the facility but I think
that should be a consideration and if
the commission was formed I would
suggest it to them
yeah
so so because this is the language that
is an sb1 as amended that for the Second
Amendment
I I would like to include this
to tell the senate look we listened we
tried to meet you where we could
they don't really have an opinion on it
all right uh representative hole oh did
you have an another thing you wanted to
say though okay representative hole
thank you chairman
um
no strong opinions either way I do think
we're putting the cart before the horse
and I say that because of line 16 and 8
through 18 right this priest opposes
that we know which town we're in if
we're trying to get a representative
from a local law enforcement agency or
Municipal governing body
um and then I think if we're going to
wholesale pick this up and put it in we
need to go past lines 35 we have to go
all the way to the end of page
um at least line two maybe line three on
page six because there's some repeals of
this section of the law that would be
incorporated
so no strong opinions but I think the
site selection is the nine is the big
thing we should be talking about and
whether if there was anything that would
be the commission to put in this
amendment that there is a well-defined
site commission maybe that language
exists from some other bill from
someplace before put that in here I
just just say your last sentence again I
I got distracted looking for something
sure so I think the key element is
making sure the site selection committee
is part of this amendment if we were
going to do something because that's the
piece of this puzzle that needs to be
solved long before we get to page five
I'm suggesting this could double as a
site selection committee particularly if
we added a line to make that part of the
their Charter there without or we have
not yet designated what a site selection
committee would look like
we're not there yet go ahead I have a
question for either
um Mr ribstone or Mr Ripple right and
this is naiveness on my part due to just
coming up to speed on this bill where
are we on site selection what was
authorized by Statute before
when
there was there was nothing authorized
by Statute specific to site selection
this went through the entire process
last year all the way to Committee of
conference with almost no conversation
about site selection that was going to
be it seemed left to the department and
Governor to resolve
um but in this session that has become
the pressing issue at least in the
Senate and a and a pressing issue here
in the house
thank you question for the chair yes
would it be possible to have a draft of
a site selection committee Amendment
kind of based on what is on page five
but with a focus more about site
selection because the Personnel might be
different that way and you might in fact
have Representatives
speaking to line 16 16-19 from all three
communities that are currently in
um that are currently under
consideration right members from Hampton
members from Concord members from
Manchester sorry Hamstead having those
as part of this to make this
both the focus of this to be more than
just safety but to be site selection and
that there's representatives from the
public from the areas of interest that
seems to make sense so let me uh let me
respond to that the way I would I would
deal uh incorporate what you just said
on line 16 I would change the phrase a
representative
to saying Representatives
from
local law enforcement agencies make that
plural so that that line
basically says bring in the potential
sites and similarly uh
do the same thing with line 18
representatives from Municipal governing
bodies
that that way they could make the they
could tailor the commission more to the
you know sort of conquered Hampstead
Manchester thing
um that that would be my approach to to
dealing with an aspect of what you just
say up there in line five six seven
somewhere in there basically add an
additional Clause to that first sentence
so it reads something like and I'll let
Mr Ripple Ward Smith this if you're okay
with the idea is uh on line five there
is established a commission to study the
public safety
of the secured Youth Development Center
and site selection
considering the surrounding communities
and and that way we get the site
selection Mission into the charter of
the commission yes sir
if I may yep um thank you
I would put it I would word Smith it
slightly differently so I'll propose it
right there has established a commission
to study the location of and the public
Rank and then to study the public safety
of I I don't that's fine I think it's
the same meaning in yours is probably
Superior language I'll defer to Mr
Ripple who actually has to generate a
note for OLS
so if that's okay we because we could
we're going to review this tomorrow
um but do you do you think you have have
we confused you or are you on top of
this
I think I get it so you want to add
basically the committee that's in
section six of this amendment for Senate
bill one uh add site selection to the
charge somewhere around line five uh
pluralize representatives from local law
enforcement enforcement agencies and
representatives from Municipal governing
bodies on line 16 through 18.
and I think otherwise it would stay the
same now do you want to keep the
reporting dates down on lines 32 and 33
as is uh I I think I think we want to
keep the first one as is the second one
starts to feel a little Superfluous like
like it just got added because the all
these commissions have two reporting
dates and that's sort of a generic
second reporting date so I don't I don't
have a strong opinion on the second
reporting date
go ahead go ahead represent hole thank
you um so in lines probably
32 right recommendations for proposed
legislation
um both for right and location I think
if we're tasking them to be a site
selection they should be recommending a
location as well so
um
and I don't know whether and someone
else may be able to speak to it a
November 1st 2023 deadline is the right
deadline for a proposed location or
should that be sooner
it does say or before
so there's there's nothing in here that
forces them to wait
good point okay
so I I know that this um there's a lot
of concern about public safety and this
um
program for
young people
but you know this pretty much focuses on
law enforcement
but I do know as just being from Concord
I do know that we often a lot of a lot
of things around the state buildings
that we're concerned about is the fire
how much the fire department can respond
I mean we do have the prison we have a
number of we have a number of
um
buildings here in the in the capital
that we have to respond to with our fire
department and this really this seems to
be only law enforcement I do see there
is a line here that talks about a
representative for municipal government
but I do think that
communities
are real
the fire and ambulance services
for these kinds of facilities are as
important I think as the law enforcement
right yeah if if I may as as a member of
the cheap seats watching the Senate go
through all this negotiation I wasn't
there you're absolutely right fire was
was part of that concern it I'm I'm like
you a little surprised it didn't make it
into the commission language and and I
would just say that they didn't ignore
it though the way they dealt with that I
think is on the very front page
um line 24. where it reads the
department shout to the extent practical
practicable Implement any reasonable
requests by the communities to ensure
the safe operation of the facility
Implement a payment in lieu of taxes
arrangement to prevent the shifting of
costs to local taxpayers and ensure
cooperation with the prospective
community so so that was meant to be you
know sit down with a community work out
Community Support
requirements and implications and let's
figure out what we the state owes you
for that support so so they didn't
ignore it they just didn't put it into
the commission Charter
and and and I I'm sort of foreshadowing
but but this line from 22 down to 33 on
page one feels
feels like something that could be in
the walner amendment or doesn't need to
be
um but if if we don't include this
because we think this is good budget
fodder for hb2
then then maybe maybe to your point
about fire and maybe other local
Services because I don't know if I mean
do we do we list them all
sewer water no you know I mean so so if
there's some generic way to tell the
commission
that they're looking at more than the
public safety issue but they're looking
at you know Community Support
Arrangements which include Public Safety
fire
Etc
well I think it would be I mean it would
be the charge of this commission I would
think to look at right and we could say
I think having the representative from
the municipal government yep probably
that person is probably going to bring
those things up right
um so so Mr Ripple
just just to help make sure that they we
we don't let have them obsess on Public
Safety on on on line five there is
established a commission to study the
community impacts of the secured Youth
Development Center to the to the
surrounding communities to include
Public Safety fire
Etc
I I I I think I think that gets us all
in line with where we want to go
yes sir
having done a lot of site plans when
there was on planning board
one of the firemen came in at one point
they were building a nice building and
it was had some very tall trees in the
back and they thought that was nice
having these trees around and the
firemen said
if this building catches on fire we want
to be able to fight the fire from all
sides you have to have access to the
rear of the building the sides of the
building otherwise we're not as
successful at putting out the fire we
have to be able to get the trucks and
whatever all the way around the building
get a good site of where where the fire
is coming out where we have to start to
to fight the fire and it made it very
logical statement that none of us ever
thought of before yeah you call the fire
department you've got this nice building
all trees surrounded and just front lawn
and that's the only place they can fight
it from the front but the fire might
have started in the back and they can't
even see it till when they drive up so
that's the kind of thing that the fire
department will come in and talk about
that most of us don't think about but
I I think that you know the idea of
having some firemen come take a look at
this proposal is is probably a good idea
okay um maybe this will just go real
quick in or out yes or no
add the commission with the the
qualifiers that that I said to Mr Ripple
uh
representative Wilder yes or no
add what add the commission from page
yeah yes yes add the commission yes
representative walner
yeah I'm fine with the commission uh
representative tolerski
I like the wording of the community
impact
um over the public safety I think it
Embraces more of what we need to learn
okay keep keep your eye on that when we
see the language tomorrow Mr Ripple
uh representative hole no opinion either
way uh representative
so since I didn't get a chance to speak
I'm going to now
um I don't have a problem with the
commission I'll say that with the bat
although I don't understand what its
intent is what its purpose is how it
ties into the selection the choice of
six or eight out of the 12 unit of 18
unit
um I mean it's an interesting
concept but it really it's really not
tied to the bill I mean we sort of
started to tie it here which is great
but again these are all issues that we
could take up with a with more time to
actually get it right if it were done
not under this rushed uh time frame so
I'm okay with it being in there not sure
what his purpose is at this point
representative stream
yeah it's fine that it'd be added
representative Mooney thank you I would
just say that you know when I read this
I see it as a commission on Public
Safety that is Paramount there is no
question and I don't really see that
tied to one location or another whether
it's where it is now or where it will be
with a site to be
determined uh I think my first choice
would be almost periodic reviews
on certain deadline dates into this
legislation from these particular
members of different departments and
Community safety personnel over a
commission that would be my first choice
so I'll take a
a no opinion I suppose on the commission
leaning no
okay so so I think I think we have a
close enough to yes
so so let's let's go ahead and put that
in there
um and
um and and then your your point about
the periodic reports
um
you know the good news is that on page
three towards the bottom starting at
line 29 there there was a reporting
process
but uh
in an effort at this point to not snatch
defeat from the jaws of Victory I I
would I would like to put a cap on what
we're going to ask of the Waller
Amendment and carry these other things
into an hb2 conversation
is that is that okay
okay
um so so that's my proposal that we that
we update the walner amendment uh with
the discussions and agreements we've
made today
and we'll look at them tomorrow
they'll come in also looking like an sb1
amendment as well so that when the chair
sends us to go do division three work
we'll looking at sb1 we've got something
to consider
comments representative Wallner
well I'm going to bring up one
one issue that
hmm
um signaled to me
um
the date that I put in was 2025 I mean I
think you saw the date which is is two
years
we know the building's going to take
longer than that to build
so I'm I'm wondering if we
push the date out or if we are just
silent on the date
we just
one reaction to that I'm I the reason I
was okay with the date that she selected
is it gets us all the way through the
next fiscal year and and since we're
going to use the budget process for some
of this I was okay with tying it to the
fiscal year process
if however you want to extend that that
date that you proposed I I would be in
favor and in support of of you picking a
date that's longer
so if you want a different date what
what what do you think I I'm just I
would like to hear what other people
think about that because I mean it just
is something that I was thinking you
know we can't ask Mr a few years from
now two years from now
we could be sitting here
trying to once again we're right up
against the deadline with no place
you know the building's not done I agree
what all right so aggressively and
violently so should we ask the
department what they think I just would
like I'd like to hear what the other
uh representative erf
what
can we go from the Department first and
Mr ribson so um we found ourselves in
this pickle because we set a date to
close the facility when we didn't yet
have a plan to replace the facility and
um you know you uh representative
Edwards wisely started us off with this
process with the chart and and that was
kind of the first disclaimer you made
right that we we put the cart before the
horse claiming that we're going to close
this facility on a date certain
without a plan yet to replace that
facility
um and I very much were and that put us
in this place where not only did we not
have a plan by the date but the impact
that that had on the workforce and the
ability to operate the facility has been
devastating
and I very much worry that having a
closure date prior to having a viable
operational place to go
is going to cause us to repeat that same
exact issue whether it's obviously two
years is better than three weeks
um but right
I think you know you need to have you
need to know where you're going next
before you close what you have today
so you just said two things you said we
could either kick the date beyond the
end of the next fiscal year to some
other dates certain or I think what you
really prefer is that we find a way to
be silent on on on the next closure date
that's right what sb1 actually says it
does have a date by which the new
facilities anticipated to be open but it
actually talks about the closure of syc
in terms of it shall be closed when the
new facility is ready to accept children
and I think that's a more reasonable way
to frame this that when you when we have
the replacement ready to accept children
is of course the date that we would
close the current facility
okay so you could find that language
yeah I'm just I'm just now looking for
that language and of course I'm looking
at I'm happy to respondent zero one nine
two do what I'm happy to respond now
all right I would say remove the date
okay
you said move or remove thank you
um and and and so we got to remove
option
and that's referred that option twice so
what if you can help us find that
language Mr ribson
oh does it start on the bottom of page
one of my Amendment line 33 where it
starts upon opening the facility shall
be referred to as blank
um nope that's not it
Mr Ripple found that
um page two six through nine the sysc
shalomy immediately be closed for
detention or admission of any child when
the secure treatment facility authorized
by this chapter is sufficiently
completed that children can be legally
and safely housed there obviously that
language is not exactly perfect from
what we're talking about but I think
there's a framework within there that
that could be adjusted there's some
dates preceding that March 1 of 2023 and
November 1 2024 what would you do with
those dates would you these were the
dates by which
um the architect should be procured and
by which the project would be completed
which of course would no longer be
relevant in the the current framework
that we're talking about well maybe the
procurement of the architect would still
be relevant but the
um the completion of the architectural
and side evaluation work is is time
sensitive because we're trying to so so
maybe leave the first date
that would make sense to me I wouldn't
have any problem with that and we've
already and actually what's what's you
know that line anticipates that we're
going to procure to do that and in fact
DPW has already procured we've already
received three bids we've already
interviewed those folks and we're in the
process of negotiating a contract but
are not going to execute a contract
until we have authority and funding to
do so okay so you you think you could
procure the qualified Architect by March
one or do you want a different date well
procurement just means starting that
process so yes we could certainly
procure because we've already done it
okay okay and then the second date the
have the project
complete by November 24th that's
impossible
so so just strike some of that
yeah I don't think that language would
make sense in the current
framework being discussed oh okay but
the date that the goat that the Opera
money has to be used by
as as the you said there's a date he has
to the projects must be completed by
almost in 2026. I I think the key date
we heard was the date that the money
needed to be obligated by had to be
obligated and again I want to be careful
with this because I am not right you're
not the expert but but I think I heard
the obligation date was the driver and
from my and it was a military
comptroller time the obligation date is
what drove tying up federal money
if you have a an obligating document the
notes the notes I have from the note
that was handed to you before said
obligated by 12 31 2024 spent by 12 31
2026. that's what was handed me again
even with that I'd want to be careful
the people who do this work would be the
again this is not critical if we just
take it out let's take it out let's
check it out and but I do I do want
um go ahead I'm sorry I'm just going to
say I think there still is the issue of
we'd have to make sure and it might
already be in here but the repeal of the
current closure date has to be included
yes Mr Ripple will probably take care of
that for us as well
right so I think that's
so
section one of both the bill as
introduced House Bill 49 as as
introduced and representative Walden's
Amendment 311h they both deal with that
uh closure date and so that was from
House Bill 2 from two years ago that's
being amended here I think that would
just need to be repealed uh if you want
what you want to do was include
the language that you just discussed
oh okay I I I think I'm good I think I'm
confident that you have good notes and
that you you can produce an amendment is
is that good
I think so
I think there's still the question of
the department is presenting two design
options but it's unclear who they're
presenting them to uh the committee from
Senate bill one does have some oversight
it's not clear that the timing would
overlap so for example there's no timing
mentioned uh in section two of this
amendment
Department would come up with two
possible options but it doesn't say by a
date certain whereas the committee would
need to issue its recommendations by
November 1st
so there are some so what if we said 30
September is no later than for the um
completion of the the two options on the
design and that met that marries up with
that Commission
but that still doesn't answer the
question of
who's actually going to make the
decision if there's going to be
legislation well I think if you left in
they would present recommendations for
proposed legislation on or before
November 1st 2023 so there would be
representative
thank you chairman if the
the information was shared I'm looking
at lines 33 and 34 right sent to the
Speaker of the House president of the
Senate house clerk Senate clerk the
governor in the State Library
their findings would be sufficient to
kick off how we deal with it as the
legislature I am very much in sync with
walner that the legislature should be
the decision-making body and not we
I'm not seeing any disagreement or
anyone that feels like they have
something to say to that representative
tolerski
representative tolersky I'd just like to
clarify something now that we started
with the walner amendment with two
million dollars appropriated for the
site evaluation architect to consult
consultation Etc
now we have a commission that we're
going to charge with the community
impacts and the site selection
are they going to have two million
dollars to spend is the department going
to move forward with this original
appropriation of two million dollars
like where are we at with this because
I'm a little confused how we got to this
point and what the end goal is are we
taking site selection away from the
Department that was going to have this 2
million for site selection
let's I just want to make sure we're all
on the same page of what we're doing by
changing we're not going to get
politicians the two million dollars
we're going to let the executive
department have the 2 million that's
what that appropriation does the value
of the commission is is basically to be
an Advisory Board to be thinking
bringing in the coordination of the
communities and considering legislation
that we could begin Hearing in January
of 24.
so I understand that
does how does that limit the department
and how they move forward do they have
to wait until the commission's done
in November and issues recommendations
before they can start some of this work
that's the disconnect
they got to go this is why we had to go
procure this architect on one March and
right and and we put we just put a 30
September date to have the design
completed no later than 30 September is
what I said is it a different date yeah
if I could respond to that okay how long
do they need for design so the the site
review would definitely be done by that
based on the conversations we've had the
actual design work would take longer
than that I think the anticipated design
process was a little closer to a year
so they would have so I think but I
think that with what I've heard right
part of the idea is that when this
committee starts meeting in September
you'll know the site which with the site
evaluation worked on people will be able
to make that decision about the site
right or at least be better informed to
make that decision about the site
but the full design process I don't
think will be done by September based on
the again DPW Public Works be the best
people to ask right no no I I don't
doubt you so Mr Ripple when I was
yakking earlier I said 30 September for
completion of
let's just make it the site evaluation
recommendation
okay and you could
you could all just you could also just
leave it silent on a date
I sensed that people wanted to know that
we were going to be making some progress
and and with this commission having to
do its first report by the first in
November and be independent upon
information being provided to it by this
contractor
the contractor should have a date to
shoot for
with sort of the minimum essential
information needed by the commission
so the minimum essential seems to be the
is 30 September adequate
for the site evaluation I think so and I
you know I don't have in front of me the
actual scope that was proposed but I
remember the site evaluation being like
the very first thing and and being
measured in like weeks or a month or so
not measured in
long term
okay so did
did that resolve your
are we still confused
and I mean us are we confused I think we
are however I just want to clarify that
the Commission Section
when we were talking about how
adding in some site-specific decision or
suggestions I want to make sure that
we're not holding back progress on this
side
that they're not going to be waiting for
a green light from the commission over
here I just wanted to make sure that all
of this is
working together yes ma'am and there's
nothing in this commission that gives it
Authority it they they come up with a
recommendation and they come up with
um proposed legislation they don't they
they're not exercising a go no-go
okay I just wanted to make sure that we
weren't putting one ahead of the other
in terms of what they were looking at
but if you're all assuring me that's not
the case then I will
put my faith in all of you no no no no
no no no no no no continue to think
about what you're thinking and and and
it'll help I think to see uh a clean
copy of the walner agree I agree uh
fresh copy yeah yeah but but don't don't
let go of that I mean if if you think we
may have missed something let's not
go ahead
we might not want to refer to site
okay I'm saying there's a there shall be
a commission and we said that shall be
responsible for Community coordination
to include aspects like law enforcement
you know just I wouldn't give them any
idea that they're selecting anything no
that no okay I I I I think I agree with
you and that's why I reread it and um
while we were going and I'm I'm happy
that there is no Authority Beyond
writing a report and proposing
legislation I also want to say that
walner
Amendment here looks very different than
walner's original Amendment so I think
there's it should be coming from this
Division and not Wallner thank you
I'll happily call it the division three
Amendment uh after we look at it and we
all are okay Mr chair I just want to
clarify that that clarification on in
your agreement that we're not putting
that site decision into the commission
that was solves my confusion okay
good good
um I would like to because I don't think
we're quite done yet we're very very
close uh I would like to close the
conversation on the proposed division
three amendment to HB 49
I'm going to say again it's going to get
I replicated in a way in which it can be
the amendment to sb1 if that's what we
want to do tomorrow
but Mr ribson has been teed up a couple
of times to come talk to us about his
numbers for what he thinks operations
may look like costs it's it's it's not
relevant to today's work session in
terms of producing an amendment it's
irrelevant because I'd like to lock down
the amendment scope that we've already
done but but I do
want to make sure that Mr ribson can
give us some numbers I think I think
this is the first public review of these
numbers is that true Mr ribson yes
that's right all right
yeah so this really just I mean just
very simple just kind of showing right
the biggest cost at sysc is the is the
Personnel costs and as as we explained
earlier today
um
you know a lot of those Personnel costs
are increased based on the fact that it
essentially operates on an island
um and that we no longer can enjoy the
economies of scale that maybe were once
envisioned if you had 144 Youth and now
you only have you know 5 12 18.
um
pardon me
so the idea is this is just kind of
showing what the anticipated Personnel
shifts would be in a shared services
model
um and there's a couple changes here
right so just to show what these lines
are and there would be other potential
savings or I'm jumping ahead there but
um you know there are costs that go to
maintaining the rest of that campus
right there's a lot of grass that needs
to be mowed there's a lot of old
buildings that we try to patch together
as best that we can and keep from
becoming dangerous
um hazards is probably the best that we
can do with them at this point
um
so there's a lot of cost that goes into
there there's also a lot of cost that
just goes in the utilities of heating
and cooling that massive building to the
tune of about 800 000 a year right so
certainly a much smaller facility would
have smaller costs and you'd lose all
those other costs associated with the
campus I haven't projected those in here
because I don't know what the next place
is right but there would be certainly
costs within there that are also all
general fund Appropriations at this
point but looking at really what is the
bulk of the cost with the facility
Staffing we do anticipate
um some significant savings really to
the tune of like I said before close to
uh you know 2 million in change in terms
of uh Staffing costs and that really is
through being able to reduce some of the
um some of the positions and either
sharing them with a future facility or
subcontracting some of that out with the
future facility that would depend on
whether you were co-locating with
Hampstead or New Hampshire hospital
right Hampstead is operated differently
than New Hampshire hospital and that
most of the services within Hampstead
are done by contracted by a contracted
entity whereas kind of the
administrative oversight is by DHHS and
the administrators are DHHS the the
staff are primarily contracted New
Hampshire hospital is more of a mix
where you have a lot of State staff but
you also have a mix of contracted staff
with Dartmouth
sysc today is more of a mix where we
have mostly State staff but we do have
some contracted staff with Dartmouth
like our psychologists our part-time
psychiatrists and our clinicians and
recently our Educators as well
um so what you see here really is just
kind of the shift in reducing some of
those positions that we would no longer
need if we were in a shared services
model and then you add in at the bottom
a couple of new contracts to replace
some of those services on the model to
the right so where you see grants for
public assistance that's actually the
education contract I don't know why it's
called that that's in our budget the
line that it would have showed up in I
don't really understand those things but
that would have been that's the
education contract and where it says
contracts for program services that
would be the contract for
um things like uh like cleaning food and
things like that if this was to be say
at Hampstead where we were Contracting
those Services out as a subcontract
through their larger contract to
maintain that facility
so with that
so I'm going to take the 64 number on
the on the right as as notional this is
not this is not obviously not a final
version of what you guys would propose
correct um and and so I I can't help
myself but when you you've listed a
switchboard operator you get two
comments we don't do switchboards
anymore
and and also if there is something that
could be shared uh with another facility
you know having somebody operate the
reception of the phone would be a
candidate this switchboard Opera like
those are just still the names that are
classification system uses no I get it
for administrative supports 1950s it was
a great decade so and I believe there's
currently an effort underway to try to
change all these by the end of this
fiscal year or at least change some of
these by the end of this fiscal year so
that might look different but but yeah
what that really is is that's the
administrator that's kind of the
admission a support team
okay all right so again again the point
is let's look at sharing as much as we
can and all right thanks do questions
representative Weiler you live out the
teachers in the second column are we
going to be remote learning no what this
anticipates so again that that thing
that says grants for public assistance
three hundred thousand dollars that
anticipates that we contract that out
which
um actually we've already started doing
our Educators have retired
all of them
and uh we entered into a contract just
recently with an entity called my turn
which does at-risk youth education in
Manchester Nashua and Franklin
um and that I'm really excited about
because you know those are also
communities where a lot of our kids come
from so it'll be a nice connection
between
what they have in their Community what
they can get at sysc and hopefully
facilitate better communication and
planning between the two operations and
you have several grades you have to
teach in several subjects it's it's very
complex and what my turn has done in
their other programs which we're excited
about is they really they already
operate in a model that really is more
of like an individualized learning model
instead of a classroom based model right
and that was kind of one of the
challenges with with our our state-run
model was right the teachers the
Educators they really were used to
running a classroom based model for
decades right because that's what the
facility always had and as the census
changed and the populations dropped and
really any given day we have kids from
all different age ranges and all
different learning needs that we need to
be able to individualize
um you know their education for and we
would accommodate that by having a
teacher work with the youth on
you know the various topics and we had
some some virtual platforms that they
could use to supplement something called
Plato uh like Plato and Socrates not
like the stuff you play with
um and uh and the vlac system which
would kind of allow some additional
expertise to let the youth work
one-on-one to learn what it is they need
to learn to go back and get credit when
they return to their home schools
um so we we've been supplementing that
stuff but it really wasn't the it wasn't
kind of the the format and skill set
that the historical staff were really
comfortable with
um so I am excited that with this new
model we're gonna we're gonna be in a
good a good spot but it is all just just
just brand new like literally this month
brand new do we need that many nurses or
is just to make sure you have 24-hour
coverage so what this anticipates is
fewer nurses than than the last it still
anticipates that we want nurses during
the during the awake hours but that for
overnights we would no longer have an on
staff nurse
um currently we do keep an on staff
nurse overnights in the case of an
emergency or in case of a late night
admission sometimes something will
happen in the middle of the night and
the kid shows up and we have to do one
of the requirements under federal and
state laws to do a physical assessment
of every kid upon admission
um in conversations with leadership at
the facilities that we'd be able to
co-locate with both thought that you
know given how unusual those
circumstances are that that's a
responsibility that a staff within those
other facilities could step in on those
unusual circumstances to be able to
cover for us so we wouldn't have to pay
somebody to you know to basically just
sit there just in case
um
and then yes of course you'll notice the
um a lot of the the maintenance laundry
those types of things are not included
on the shared service model
um right we have plenty of Need For
Those folks there's other places in the
department that can absorb them whether
that's a Hampstead or um or New
Hampshire hospital or somewhere else but
they'd be able to be part of kind of
that larger system and not not um you
know running a separate small facility
uh there was one other group here that
and slipped my mind oh the kitchen staff
so so I would just add to this that um I
don't know that it's time sensitive but
since we just set up the architect to do
six to 12 and 12 to 18 you might need to
be thinking the same thing about your
operational Staffing would would it
would there be any difference I assume
it would be a tiny difference
it would be it would be relatively small
difference
um right when even right now when we're
working with 12 kids or 18 kids it
really is a relatively small difference
because it's really about how many units
you have to run to keep Kids Safe I
don't expect it to be a big number but I
I just do want us to Think Through what
that number is and I'll just address
right up front I'm sure some folks look
at that 45 youth counselor number and
say why do you need that many for this
few kids and I will say you know the
lesson over the last year is that we
still need a large pool of Frontline
milieu staff we might think differently
about how we manage those folks and it's
one of the things that might come out in
those conversations with this committee
that you're talking about the safety
we've been looking at models that other
states use you know do you think about
shifting that role right now our
Frontline youth counselors are our
milieu staff they're really both
responsible for the primary security
role and the primary kind of interaction
treatment de-escalation role and it
might be worth thinking about you know
do you kind of separate some of those
functions out and have a smaller team of
folks who are more focused on security
and let your other staff be really
really heavily focused on your kind of
treatment de-escalation I still think it
would be the same number overall but it
would be kind of a different
categorization of how you utilize your
your Workforce all right representative
Wallner
I just I just wondered you you did just
say that you had had some preliminary
discussions with a couple of the
locations
with not not with the town folks with
the with the administration of the
facilities with the facilities yeah so
would you have some sort of interagency
agreement that you would have to pay I
mean you're going to obviously have to
pay for food yep yeah it would have
depending on which site it would differ
right if it was New Hampshire hospital
it'd really probably be kind of more
through the budget process and how we
structure the budget between the two
facilities if it was Hampstead where a
lot of those functions are already done
under contract it would have to be kind
of through a contract Amendment with the
entity that does a lot of that work but
either way yeah there'd have to be a
formal structure for that
uh representative Mooney
oh you were pointing over here
representative
uh thank you Mr chair
can you just tell us why the sununu
grounds is still even in the running as
as I said there's significant
disadvantages to that to that site
that being said until we've actually
determined that there is an adequate
piece of land parcel of land on the
other sites you know it's hard to
eliminate that site as a possibility and
that you know site selection work hasn't
yet been completed to be sure that we
have an appropriate physical plant site
for New Hampshire hospital co-location
or Hampstead co-location
but I think you know the current the
current site is you know comes with
so there's quite a cost to making that
determination I'm just you know we've
been talking about this for years I'm
just wondering why that little piece of
the puzzle wouldn't have already been
answered
well that's again that's work that was
that the intent was that you would build
that into the contract with the with the
design firm right and we've never been
authorized to go forward to do that work
so that was the that was kind of always
the plan in the intent of how this was
going to move forward I suppose there
could have been another way to approach
that but
um and again I'd also point to right
last year we went through this whole
process and nobody seemed to be you know
so concerned about the site location so
that was just kind of a normal
well it didn't come up at the committee
of conference I don't remember that
being even a much of a conversation even
in division three to my memory
it was a Hot Topic when we were talking
about the secure forensic hospital and
conquered sensitivities to having things
jammed on them but but you're right I
think you're right are there any other
questions so so at this point Mr Ripple
you're the most important man in the
room
so so so I just want to hear you
summarize what you think you're going to
be doing and and then and then we'll
foreign sure
um
so we'll start with the beginning
starting with Amendment 311h as a as a
starting point
uh the first section rather than
revising the dates
will repeal section 329 of house bill 2.
that was the part that closed the sununu
center effective March 1st of this year
section two of that Amendment the two
million dollar appropriation for design
options will remain in with some
additional language stating the
department shall consider two design
options one for six to twelve bed
facility and one for 12 to 18 bed
facility
there will be a date of
September 30th in there for the site
evaluation option but not for the two
you will keep in
the section from the bill as introduced
that appropriates 1.5 million dollars
for operating costs for the rest of this
you will keep in
part of the paragraph that's on page two
lines three through nine
but you'll remove the provision about
completion of the project on or before
also from Senate bill one
section 6 with various modifications one
is in addition to
the commission will be renamed rather
than a public safety commission it will
assess the community impacts which will
include Public Safety fire safety and
other related factors
it will also
consider a site location
down on lines 16 through 19 will make
sure that it contains representatives
from local law enforcement agencies and
representatives from Municipal governing
bodies
I'm not sure that anything needs to
change there although I do have a note
about site selection so maybe that
should specify that the preliminary
report will include a recommendation as
and I don't think anything else about
so that's what I have okay and then just
double check the repeal dates that are
on page six just to make sure we didn't
just missed something administratively
sure all right I I think that's a good
summary did he miss anything did anyone
pick up on okay I think that's good
um Mr ribson thank you so much for your
patience uh the child advocate is here
do you have any words of wisdom for us
foreign
thank you
um I would just like to share the
importance in considering therapeutic
components at the current facility while
the other facility is being built I know
that was included in Senate bill one and
was a very important aspect for the care
of the children that are already there
we want to ensure that they are
receiving the appropriate treatment so
any questions
I I think we heard you
um and uh we are not done we're going to
continue through the hb2 process uh and
and then this commission obviously is
still alive so all right uh anyone else
uh the our our friend in the very back
with the mask did you have anything to
say to us
oh okay all right well I'd say with that
division three work session is adjourned
yeah
well until the next one which is
tomorrow right after full Finance
but that's a separate distinct work
session so
all right so this work session I think
is done
I think